the harvest is in full swing at the
venezia plantation
the ripe coffee beans have to be picked
and processed as quickly as possible
coffee production is a key industry in
colombia
but the cafeteros have been facing
disaster for years
with falling prices on the world market
many farmers are close to bankruptcy
and now they're facing a crisis of a
different sort
a plague of destructive black beetles is
causing huge losses
the biggest problem here in the region
is the coffee bora beetle
a tiny insect that causes tremendous
damage to coffee beans
it bores into them and lays its eggs
there
the beetle larvae hatch in them and make
the beans unsellable then the larvae
develop into beetles fly away and do the
same to other plants
this is the colombian research center
run by bayer crop science a subsidiary
of the german pharmaceuticals giant
the scientists here are working hard to
develop a pesticide against the beetle
there's no effective way to fight
infestations
when developing new chemicals for use in
pest control you must be quicker than
the competition
thanks to the climatic conditions in
colombia we're able to conduct tests and
gather data here all year long
and we can use that information in bs
projects
in addition we're able to address the
specific problems faced by the farmers
here
colombia's farmers want to sell more of
their products abroad and that means
that they have to learn more about
international norms
oranges exported for example to europe
are subject to very strict regulations
beatrice arietta heads a bayer teaching
program called agrovida
it trains farmers in a variety of
agricultural methods including the right
way to treat orange trees with highly
toxic substances to protect them from
fungal infestation
programs like these ensure that the
farmer's produce can acquire the
necessary certification for sale in the
eu and they also help protect the
environment
every year we train around 22 000 people
to use pesticides safely
this project is supported by every
member of bayer's international sales
staff
every sales representative at bayer is
also responsible for ensuring that users
are given the information they need to
use the products properly
one of bayer's most important production
facilities in latin america can be found
at the municipality of barankia on the
colombian coast
around 160 staff members work in several
shifts a day here
the agrochemical sector is booming as
more land is devoted to agriculture in
countries all over the world
but many companies want a slice of this
growing market
in colombia is up against both u.s and
swiss chemicals companies
so his prices have to convince
a very competitive location because the
people who we train there ourselves are
highly qualified
and the geographic location is also good
strategically from here we can serve not
only the colombian market but also the
andes region venezuela ecuador peru and
even the export markets of brazil and
argentina it allows us to adjust quickly
to the needs of those markets
today's crop of coffee beans from the
venesia plantation is ready for delivery
the workers here are hoping for a good
harvest and rising prices
and of course that the plague of beetles
will soon end
the company that can offer a pesticide
to make that happen more quickly is
certain to do well in colombia